hier ist das erste deutsche fernsehen
mit der tagesschau
[Musik]
hier bekommen sie einen neuen folge 3
kauft die
[Musik]
barmittel edition mit dem kospi waffe
könnte man christen die eine zutat die
wir heute brauchen ihr wisst ja was das
thema des heutigen videos sein wird
geburtstag kopf denn ich habe heute
geburtstag ein bisschen überlegen in
welchem opfer
alles gute
[Musik]
ja und weil ich werde in kürze cup ist
das thema natürlich dann heute drei
geburtstag zu helfen als draußen bleiben
dass die halten
so das macht meiner rein auf den tischen
sitzen rettungsmaßnahmen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wir waren einkaufen kelly und freddy hat
uns die sachen geschrieben die er haben
jetzt packen wir sie auf dem tisch und
stellen sie uns vor wer möchte anfangen
ich stelle mir das mal vor sich auf dem
tisch
ich sage mir das nicht einfach dahin
zaubern die sind alles durcheinander ich
glaube müssen produzieren naja mäßig
schnitt
warten wir verstecken unsere gesichter
[Musik]
wie war
noch mal eben weil wir geben uns keine
mühe vor dem video sind jetzt unsere
zutaten ende märz vorstellen nein nie
dachte
ich weiß jetzt war ich habe heute
geburtstag ja sagen ein bisschen
besondere handlung ist ganz schön nett
zu mir sein dann immer dass ich sagen
und märchen sind zwischen leben und
dadurch gerade im schnitt gehört habe da
ich sowieso immer voll viel aber melone
alan das berliner luft streit malibu
brause und so präsentieren sie weg ich
nicht weil ich nicht so viel reden sie
mäßig und natürlich nicht genannt wenn
das video ist du kannst du hast gesagt
ich dachte es hat einer von den katzen
endlich
[Gelächter]
die strawberry sind krimis mit indischen
big news limited edition schlagsahne
mädchen führt zu steifen rechte viel
stoff des registry weil du exklusiv bist
ach du scheiße
widerstände vielfalt in deinem charakter
ist so sieht die farben in diesen
streuseln für papier strohhalme wenn du
nachts willst gehst du ein
und sogar
ist der dass man abschluss
problem ist vanessa ich habe immer etwas
schon gemerkt dass wir die gleiche idee
haben das heißt es wird wirklich nass
sie heute obwohl sie geburtstag hat und
fand ich es auch da ging ja also der
kampf für die heute wirklich serie denn
ich habe auch milch sahne durch den
magen
[Musik]
damit kann man eins oder creme kann man
damit machen das sind die gar nicht das
sind unsere nachbarn
aber ich mache weiter man hört mich an
geht er jetzt nicht beim anstoßen
erdbeermarmelade
krönchen track
koteletts tat lässt also man erkennt ja
schon mit den kuchen und mit den links
ich gehe schon in seinem geburtsort in
richtung und das ist ungefähr so gibt es
darf ich ein
wenn du alt ist es sich auch alle ich
möchte kein abo kann sprecher in essen
ein leid geklagt
was haben wir meine gegend erlebnis
seine so alt wie das funktioniert die
neue frau in seinem leben und wir fühlen
uns angeht ja ich glaube auch ich ja wir
sind einfach sehr in unsere weiblichkeit
verletzt nur soweit ich hin und her wie
birthday und natürlich frische erdbeeren
und
bitte sag nicht willkommen bei den durst
spiel
mögen die dort viele
beckmann
[Musik]
hast du da gefriergetrocknete er ja von
coro ja
[Musik]
du kannst dich
wir haben gerade erst angefangen
[Musik]
es ist ein bisschen so aus wie so ein
kind das von seinen eltern zu so einer
veranstaltung mit hingebracht wurde und
nicht ganz klar kommt auf das was gerade
passiert
gleich wieder spielen
ich schneide jetzt einfach mal sagen ich
habe die letzten
ich habe folgende sachen gemacht sie
waren zusammen einkaufen das ist heuer
vorteile ich sagen ich habe magath wir
sind
alle so mag ich mir dabei gedacht
dass
ich so ich muss mal kurz rein sahne
schlagen dann wird es ganz einfach ich
habe nun mal gelesen hier vorne sieht
nach nachdrücklich
[Musik]
kurz durchschlagen machst das jetzt so
das läuft schon gut machen können so
was mal machen uns doch neue das würde
ich mal werden sehen ja eigentlich schon
heute macht das die cocktails die
bba'ler abende gemacht haben es aber
auch bei einem cocktail noch gemacht den
will keiner nachmachen glaube ist bei
dir müssen sie einfach nur eine
wassermelone ausfüllen
den beutel inhalt mit etwas sonne viel
zucker mischen noch und unter ständigen
schlag langsam in die samen ergeben das
hatte ich verzweifle ich
schon mal benutzt
first time aber ich das erste mal dass
ich was mache
[Musik]
und sonst also
ein gewinn war gerade auf hochtouren
schon lustig überfordert
weil deshalb vielleicht für mich private
frage eher zitrone waldmeister himbeere
orange was dein liebstes davon oh
ja ich hab da so eine idee du
aber es wird jetzt immer wilder es tut
mir leid es ist voll das timing von
haina wir drehen grafen video aber alle
da ist der name
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sehr süß aber alles stellt heraus dass
der clip aller zeiten des beatles immer
auf dem weg zu sein
bitte müssen was fürs video von vanessa
sagen ich halte ans mikro
wer ist vanessa
[Applaus]
bodenlos gerade kondensmilch die ziffern
oder was
nachher keine ein paar fragen aussuchen
das motto fragen
fragen
langweilige mittags
das wirklich noch alles so richtig
vornehmen wo ist ihr lieblingsort in der
stadt man gibt die tat intent ist die
ehrenstraße und weil hier kelly
ist ihr lieblingsort in der stadt
in meinem bett
welche app hat ihr leben wirklich besser
gemacht
hirai scanner mit eis gerners
gamestreamer dokument sollen
google maps das sieht aus wie day schon
ein paar tage auf den straßen lag und
die autos über die grenzen das ist genau
die farbe würde wenn wir jetzt leise
sind dann können wir den kompletten
audio von calyon verhandlungen
ja ich habe eine eiswaffel für dich mit
gefunden
[Musik]
ganz am anfang kochen habe ich vergessen
also ich hinein suchen
dann weggeschmissen wenig bekommen
hast du auch so was gekauft
ich bin ich bin ja auch frei blitz war
in wenigen sekunden alles ordentlich ist
hallo ich bin wieder da
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
dann habt ihr marken
armani essen aber dafür zu tun potters
team macht gleich selber kaputt für und
du kriegst halt crazy denn für nur einen
schluck von dem 5
ich sag mal so die sind jetzt fertig und
wir können jetzt probieren wer will
anfang
ich nenne meine batida de vries
ich wollte es lustig wird aber es kam
nur scheiße das ist super lecker und da
dazu gibt es noch für dich etwas funky
mäßiges als brause und dann immer mit
der heimat berliner luft gefüllt damit
dass so ein bisschen ist wie berliner
kindl was alle lieben in berliner kinder
so lecker cook und jetzt was passiert
bis bereit ich bin ich extra befragte
zeugen
der lina
sperma prozent auch noch so ein bisschen
das wenigste und du musst jetzt zuerst
das trinken und dann davon schlug man
deshalb habe ich extra für dich gemacht
vormachen
als auch erst mal ein stückchen hiervon
[Musik]
man hier ein gesicht leihen das
irgendwie sind lecker fruchtig das ist
wie urlaub weil das hat man sich ja auch
mal verdient am geburtstag und dann so
ein bisschen minze noch das wird es
schmeckt wirklich gut zusammen da kommen
muss ist der hammer ist der effekt guck
mal wie sie hin und hergerissen der
ganze körper machen
da wird es richtig gut schmecken ja
ist lecker lecker so richtig aus ganz
schön wenig rum er ist übel lecker
gewesen
das ist beleidigend auch ein bisschen
also man trinkt hat das sind dann hat
man somit das macht wahlkampf rot weiß
ich würde sagen im instant gerade so
bekommen haben war ich fertig und meiner
bedarf ein bisschen präsentation also
wie gesagt heute wieder mit aufgebaut
[Musik]
deshalb instant aufgehört
ich dachte ich mache weil sie an
geburtstags fraktion ist eine
geburtstagstorte im glas deswegen habe
ich unten ein bisschen kuchenstücke
vanillecreme 1
und hier ist ja auch ein kuchen es von
hostess erdbeere weil ich bin
einerseits an arbeit bin ich vom
sternzeichen ein solches erdbeere und
mein bruder
erdbeere ist mein element von dem
geburtstag der er war
meine großmutter erzählte mir oft
geschichten über eine längst vergangene
zeit
und während
werden
und in einem verdammten mehr besuchen
also und dann ist es ein virgin cocktail
weil ich eine jungfrau ist kein alkohol
drin ist es eine premiere ich glaube das
ist unser allererster das geht nicht das
ist betrug das darf man nie was
passieren muss die ballern oder
was geht
es ist nicht schön das ist kein cocktail
man sorgen milchshake das ist kein
cocktail das meine psx ist wirklich so
stimmt koalition leute ja und ein schub
babies reingemacht hätte
[Musik]
ja so stimmen kelly zu was er gesagt hat
ist einfach frische ja und das ist doch
ist das einfach nur king aber dass ich
mich
[Gelächter]
irgendwie hier versagten ihm eine
alkoholfreie cocktails
für was steht kopf schwanz schwanz
und jetzt kommt
[Gelächter]
mit dem kunden der da drin ist er
ziemlich extra
dem kickboxen machen kann dieses gewesen
du darfst als erster sieger cocktailbar
schon mal probiert
dann nimmst jetzt mit den ganz großen
schluck immer noch ein großes hakenkreuz
aber moment der das ähnlich schlecht ich
habe gar keinen bock drauf was heißt nur
noch reingemacht base und t doch unter
euch mal
das ist ein komisches sollen
was wirklich wichtig ist
gegenwärtig sei das nicht okay das ist
so
bitter das brennt ganz schön doll ihr
auch ja
ich weiß nicht was hier mal
ich glaube kelly wir wir sind uns einig
dass wenn das ein cocktail wäre dann
würde vanessa heute gewinnen ab die
zuschauer entscheiden das einfach gut
für kommentare
sowie aber seit wann steht denn in der
cocktail bibel dass man eiswürfel da
drin haben muss da sein müssen cocktail
haben
taylor hätte meine definition von
cocktails schwarzwalds werden schon
geklärt fertig schwarz schwarz ist ein
alkoholisches nicht ein
ansonsten wäre es ein model
okay wir sagen jetzt mal unseren
gewinner auf 31 23
ja ich keine aus von alles scheiße heute
machen wir ab 30.000 likes
[Musik]
mehr